oh look awesome
okay look help see there my friend it's
okay
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh God oh okay
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Thank You Ronnie are you okay oh yeah
sure yo don't touch don't touch
office I'm so gonna use you did good
good good good good work good job thank
you you can go um took some water thank
you so much yes okay
now look good at all yeah was it look
like [ __ ] thickest champ let's wait
till / what okay because I can't reach I
just need you could go get down there
and just down no I can't do that though
come on did you push it out okay oh hi
I'm gonna help you
we're going to displace the situation
together okay okay okay think about
things that turn you off maybe like like
your grandma's on where mm-hmm okay
maybe like good posture just very still
stuck yeah
hey no go knee damage don't bring the
children hey Mitchell snitches here Rana
you pumped about the qualifiers buddy
you know it man I'm just I'm really
really excited to equip my double major
in robotics in computer science and
really really do something with my life
you don't need to look down there
do not touch you're not even touching
okay Wow okay I'm sorry you got your
beef and your biscuit stuff down it's
gonna be okay
I've been through it too not a big deal
yeah absolutely I was stuck in a woman
for hours one couldn't get out here
summers biggest comedy arrived you just
said look at my boobs
Oh worse daring whoa guys does anybody
see this home where he won't stop
staring at my boobs I'm not welcome to
Baywatch that we're old Baywatch
[Music]
you